[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le
débat de france 24 le sommet du g7 s'est
poursuivi ce lundi dans les alpes
bavaroises au sud de l'allemagne et
c'est bien sûr la guerre en ukraine qui
était au coeur des discussions les sept
pays les plus industrialisés de la
planète ont réaffirmé leur aide à kiev
ils ont promis de continuer à soutenir
le pays dans tous les domaines aussi
longtemps qu'il le faudra ce matin par
visioconférence le président ukrainien
volodimir zelensky leur a demandé de
faire le maximum pour mettre fin à la
guerre avant l'hiver mais ce réaliste
alors que la russie poursuit son avancée
à l'est dans le donbass y at-il un
risque après quatre mois de guerre d'une
fatigue du camp occidental comme l'a
évoqué hier boris johnson le premier
ministre britannique les sanctions mises
en oeuvre jusque là par les occidentaux
ont elles déjà un impact sur moscou et
peuvent elles vraiment changé le cours
de cette guerre on va en débattre avec
nos invités ce soir patrick martin
geniez enseignant à sciences po
spécialiste des questions européennes
bonsoir merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
sur ce plateau michel aulas garaï
vice-amiral ancien commandant de l'école
navale bonsoir soit christian de
boissieu plateau est également
professeur émérite à l'université paris
1 vice président du cercle des
économistes
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous ce soir
et par skype de tft tiana hoggar kova
journaliste ukrainienne responsable du
département international à l'ukraine
crisis elle media center tetyana hoggar
kova bonsoir merci d'être avec nous ce
soir on va d'abord prendre la direction
de garmisch partenkirchen au coeur des
alpes bavaroises c'est là que se tient
ce g7 en ce moment on va y retrouver
benoît de bruno daroux pas benoît bruno
notre envoyé spécial bonsoir ce g7
clairement il a pris des allures de
conseil de guerre aujourd'hui pour
soutenir l'ukraine
oui absolument que les robes pour
soutenir l'ukraine et puis aussi pour
envoyer un message d'extrême fermeté
vis-à-vis de la russie
puisque lors de ce conseil il s'agissait
de montrer que les dirigeants
occidentaux pouvaient encore décider de
nouvelles sanctions et combattre en fait
l'influencé russe en ukraine alors la
solidarité avec l'ukraine allaient été
affiché dans un communiqué le temps
qu'il faudra vous l'avez dit une aide
militaire diplomatique humanitaire qui
sera déployée par les dirigeants du g7
des livraisons d'armes aussi comme le
réclame le président hélène ski qui
s'est invitée ce matin à la session de
travail avec les dirigeants du g7 et qui
a estimé effectivement qu'il fallait
aller très vite donc on comprend qu'ils
réclament aux occidentaux une aide
militaire accrue pour que la guerre
puisse se terminer avant l'hiver son
raisonnement en fait c'est que si
l'hiver arrive et que la situation
militaire n'est pas réglé bien le front
sera gelé à cause de cet hiver très rude
en ukraine et ça veut dire donc ça
repartira au printemps c'est en tout cas
le souhait du président zelensky les
américains qui ont déjà fourni des armes
les français les allemands aussi les
américains disent qu'ils pourraient
fournir des missiles sol air
assez vite pour aider les ukrainiens
donc effectivement ça a été au coeur de
cette journée là quand même eu d'autres
thématiques du g7 qui ont été abordés
avec les pays du sud qui ont été invités
comme l'inde où l'un d'eux pipe
si on traîne puisque il s'agit sont en
train d'en discuter de crise alimentaire
notamment il y a eu quand même des
petites dissensions au sein au sein de
ses dirigeants du g7 le g7 qui
reprochent notamment la russie de
provoquer une crise alimentaire mondiale
bruno
oui alors dans le communiqué le g 7 e
condamne le fait que la russie bloquent
donc c'est à peu près 22 millions de
tonnes qui sont dans le port d'odessa
prévient aussi les pays qui
encouragerait cette insécurité
alimentaire de concert avec la russie de
sanctions ce n'est pas vraiment précisé
et puis sur les sanctions quand même
contre la russie je voulais quand même y
revenir un instant on sent notamment que
le débat sur le plafonnement du prix du
pétrole ne fait pas l'unanimité
notamment entre les américains et les
français l'idée en fait c'est d'éviter
un emballement spéculatif de ces prix du
pétrole consécutif à la décision des
occidentaux de ne plus importer
progressivement de pétrole russe d'ici
la fin de l'année et évidemment donc ça
crée automatiquement en fait un effet
spéculatifs alors les américains disent
il faut plafonner le pétrole russe les
français notamment disent oui ça c'est
bien mais c'est pas suffisant en fait il
faut que d'autres acheteurs accepte
aussi un prix plafonné du pétrole alors
il pense notamment à deux gros acheteurs
du pétrole russe l'inde et la chine qui
ont fortement augmenté quand même leurs
achats de pétrole auprès de la russie ce
qui fait que certains économistes
estiment que pour les pour les le budget
russe en fait les recettes venant du
pétrole n'ont pas tellement baissé pour
l'instant à cause de ses achats de pays
comme l'inde ou la chine merci beaucoup
bruno daroux notre envoyé spécial à
garmisch partenkirchen
on va en reparler dans quelques instants
de ces sanctions occidentales contre
moscou mais avant d'en débattre
j'aimerais qu'on fasse un point sur la
situation sur le terrain en ukraine ce
g7 il se déroule alors que la russie
gagne du terrain dans le donbass à l'est
la ville clé de severodonetsk est tombé
la semaine dernière est licite chose que
devrait suivre garder
un toit au feu un nuage de fumée noire
et des ukrainiens sous le choc un
missile russe s'est abattue sur ce
centre commercial selon le président
ukrainien qui a relayé cette vidéo sur
son compte facebook plus de 1000 civils
étaient sur place au moment du
bombardement
le centre commercial est en feu les
pompiers combattent les incendies le
nombre de victimes est impossible à
imaginer ils ne représentaient aucun
danger pour l'armée russe aucune valeur
stratégique seulement des gens qui
tentaient de vivre une vie normale ceux
qui héritent tellement l'occupant russe
il est vain d'espérer une quelconque
humanité de la part de la russie à 500km
de craie mentchouk les mêmes fumée
épaisse s'élève dans le ciel d'est en
ouest les combats s'intensifient en
ukraine dans les rues désertées de
l'iscid chance qu'au nord du dombass les
tirs de lance-roquettes retentissent
les militaires d'ukrainiens s'éloigne
vers le front à bord de véhicules
blindés
la situation est difficile mais nous
tenons nos positions c'est dur près de
cent mille habitants résidaient à l'itie
de chances qu'avant la guerre les
évacuations se poursuivent les lycées de
chances que c'était une horreur on ne
pouvait plus endurer ça
il y avait tellement de bombardement de
maisons détruites
lycée de chances que va-t-elle tomber
comme la ville voisine de severodonetsk
seule une rivière sépare les deux sites
et les ponts ont été détruits cette
progression sur le terrain est crucial
pour la russie si kiev père ce bastion
industriel
c'est la moitié du dombass qui serait
son contrôle de l'armée
tetiana hoggar cauvin vous êtes à à kiev
on l'a dit il ya eu une nouvelle frappe
dans le centre du pays aujourd'hui il ya
eu aussi des frappes à kiev hier qui ont
touché une zone résidentielle qu'essaye
de faire la russie
la russie et cei de faire peur alors
qu'a débuté ce g7 et que les occidentaux
tente d'accentuer la pression contre
moscou
oui tout à fait depuis quatre jours des
gens en fait on constate que
l'intensification de frappe par missiles
et il est bien sûr question de cet
affreux attentat à cris matthew coon
région de poltava et il ya quelques
heures aujourd'hui et aussi qui y vivent
mais avant qui y vivent y avait vomi
ciel qui ont tombé sur un village à 150
km2 qui disent nature neil gaydon mire
donc depuis quatre jours c'est très
symptomatique on voit l'augmentation en
nombre de ces missiles parfois lancé
cette attention c'est important después
le territoire de bill rousse depuis les
avions c'est à dire il s'agit du missile
qui arrive depuis les avions est aussi
un certain nombre de missiles notamment
sur qui les ont lancées 14 missiles
depuis la mer de gaspi ça c'était 14
missiles d'eau uniquement 4 soit atterri
sur la capitale ukrainienne donc on
roule issa donc on se pose des questions
mais pourquoi aujourd'hui pourquoi
maintenant puisque c'est vrai que depuis
un certain temps qu'ils font en tout cas
été épargnée de ses frappes de missiles
et même on ne s'était pas un nombre de
missiles comme ça on lit cela notamment
à des succès en fait de l'airbus
craignent un dans le bassin de la mer
noire puisque juste avant il y avait
cette attaque de l'armée kényane contre
les plateformes de d'extraction du gaz
qui étaient importantes pour l'armée
russe comme les plafonds pour
renseignements mais aussi contre lille
de serpents en fait qui a été ensuite à
une opération militaire de lucre et éco
presque à ce moment là je je peux me
tromper mais parce que l'opération est
en cours mais a fêté les presque mot
presque rasé en fait de la présence
russe donc ensuite il y avait bien sûr
des menaces que la russie allait frapper
sur ce qu'ils appellent le centre de la
prise des décisions
paradoxalement on saura trop avec école
maternelle détruites actifs qui
représentait concentre de la prise de
décision malheureusement au conte le
centre commercial aujourd'hui un cri ni
tubes y avait mille perso il pouvait y
avoir mais personne ne présente au
moment de la frappe donc c'est une
tactique de la vengeance et je peux
confirmer ce qu'on a beaucoup voyagé en
ukraine que ces tactiques de la
vengeance contre les succès contre la
résistance que l'armée russe rencontre
sur le terrain ça existe par exemple
aborder un camp
village qui située au nord de kif ils
ont bombardé dès les premiers jours de
la guerre les mw plusieurs étages ils
ont lancé des véritables bombes sur des
immeubles civils c'était clair et net
c'était civile pour se venger contre sur
voilà sur les la résistance qu'elles ont
rencontrées sur le terrain donc c'est
lié à cela mais bien sûr c'est aussi
veiller comme le signe de 26 n'y
signalent en faite agissent est aussi le
signe l union européenne globalement
puisque jeudi dernier on a reçu cette
nouvelle sur le statut de candidat infor
accordé à l'ukraine donc c'est une
espèce de montrer que la force peut
peser plus que les décisions des le cren
où les décisions de la civilisation on
va dire occidental donc la rue c'est le
moment de dire s'il serait d'accord et
que la russie peut frapper partout
michel aulas garde on voit
intensification des bombardements
des prises à l'est dans le don de base
sévère aux deux nièces peut-être bientôt
les sites chance que clairement vos le
dîneur zelensky a pressé les occidentaux
de faire le maximum pour arrêter la
guerre d'ici la fin de l'année est ce
que c'est réaliste deux remarques la
première c'est que bombarder par tous en
ukraine est une stratégie de la russie
c'est à dire maintenir le sous pression
à la fois le sentiment de résistance et
autres donc ça ils le font régulièrement
elles vivent et autres mais surtout en
parallèle de ces événements
diplomatiques notamment ce gsm et la
deuxième est la deuxième bien sûr c'est
que actuellement se tiennent alors
successivement une quantité de des
vêtements et de et de réunion comme
l'union européenne qui a
admis la candidature de l'ukraine et la
moldavie la réunion actuellement du g7
qui il faut le rappeler est une réunion
informelle et à but économique qui fait
que le dernier communiqué du g7 qui
étaient longues comme c'est pas permis
le 24 mars disait tout et n'importe quoi
et encourager même le président de sinn
ski à dire allant jusqu'à la victoire
puisque le g7 qui est une réunion
économique informelle demandé à ce que
la russie kit toutes les frontières tous
les territoires y compris donc la crimée
ce qui fait que ça a donné un fol espoir
je crois aux ukrainiens ce qui n'est pas
tout à fait raisonnable lorsqu'on veut
peut-être un jour aller vers les
négociations est actuellement l'otan se
présentent aussi cette réunion de l'otan
qui est extrêmement importante qui va se
tenir à madrid il va devenir madrid et
pas simplement pour l'acceptation de la
suède et la finlande mais aussi parce
qu'il y aura la définition du nouveau
concept militaire de l'otan autant 2030
et ça nous en parlerons peut-être après
je vais pas m'étendre là dessus mais il
y à de nombreuses questions qui se
posent en particulier et bien sûr la
position que l'assemblée nationale
nouvellement élu en france pour
apprendre vis-à-vis de certains
engagements et de certaines propositions
de l'otan patrick martin legner quand
vous le lirez lenski dit qu'il faut
arrêter la guerre d'ici la fin de
l'année est ce que c'est c'est possible
et ce qu'ils en ont les moyens les
occidentaux aujourd'hui non ça me semble
complètement et réaliste et faut rendre
hommage à cette capacité de résistance
du peuple ukrainien de son président
mais vous savez il ya beaucoup d'
incantatoire depuis un certain temps on
dit beaucoup de choses et réalité ce
n'est pas réaliste quand on sait que
cette guerre dans le donbass également
dans la crimée dure depuis 2014 on ne
voit pas bien comment d'un seul coup par
une baguette magique et bien cette
guerre pourrait prendre fin dans le
donbass à cet été cet été on disait cet
été à prendre a dit au mois de décembre
est bien évidemment que ça va continuer
après depuis 2000 14 il se bat alors les
objectifs du gouvernement ukrainien ont
été réduits en ce sens qu'on disait il
faut désormais revenir aux frontières
d'avant le 24 février donc c'est encore
une guerre de positions on prend acte
d'une guerre de positions mais bien
évidemment que cette guerre ne prendra
pas fin d'ici cet été où la fin de
l'année on le sait très bien c'est
parfaitement irréaliste sts et le fait
que vladimir poutine sera se rappelle à
la mémoire de tous les dirigeants
occidentaux réunis en bavière en
bombardant à la fois kiev écrit
mentchouk qui est dans le sud dans le
dans le centre de l'ukraine montrent
bien qui n'a pas du tout l'intention
d'abandonner son objectif une frappe qui
est qui a fait au moins 10 morts an
selon le gouverneur de la région
christian de boissieu cette guerre elle
se joue sur le terrain bien sûr mais
elle est aussi économique est-ce que
l'ukraine a les moyens de tenir sur le
long terme
je dirais je dirais oui
même si la situation économique est
terrible en ukraine indépendamment ou en
plus de la situation militaire
humanitaire etc mais on les aide il faut
continuer à les aider à la fois sur le
plan militaire sur le plan
je dirais de l'assistance humanitaire
moi je voudrais revenir sur un point que
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure il
concerne la crise alimentaire bon parce
qu'on est tous nous quand on est en
france on est un peu impressionnés par
la hausse des prix du pétrole à dire
grosso modo on meurt pas si les prix du
pétrole passe à 2-2 devint de 42 euros
le litre il ya des pays qui sont en
train d'être exposés à une famine famine
et des émeutes de la faim je pense à
l'egypte jeu je vais comme d'autres tu
es assez souvent dans les pays du
maghreb je considère que ça a été abordé
au g7 si en train d'être abordés on
essaie ça a été abordé la cet après-midi
jouer mais les anglais décide d'arrêter
de le g7 il fait d'excellents diagnostic
ou qu'on peut partager difficile de les
contester un so what qu'est ce qui se
passe derrière et cet écart entre dirait
des communiqués qui sont à la fois
brillant de certaines façons très
généraux de l'autre et pas engageantes
par ailleurs cet écart entre ce qui se
dit en allemagne comme dans les
précédentes réunions du g7 ailleurs et
est-ce qu'on fait pas et quand même le
problème central on a un vrai problème
de crédibilité
il ya un vrai débat sur la gouvernance
mondiale alors je comprends bien qu'on
traite pas ces problèmes là on g20 parce
que parce que dans le g20 en principe
qui a l'air aussi même si elle a été un
peu mise à l'écart la russie a dit
aujourd'hui qu'elle allait elle allait
participer elle est invitée mais enfin
bon est invité je comprends qu'elle est
partie pas j'ajoute d'ailleurs que sur
le plan économique
amiral on est bien d'accord sur le fait
que depuis soixante-quinze première
réunion du g7
lors du jour c'était large y compris
vers les sujets donne économique on peut
le regretter et la puissance économique
a bien baissé c'était 66% en 75 c'est
plus que 45 on peut le regretter parce
que je dirais il ya eu un élargissement
des domaines traités et une perte
d'approfondissement absolument c'est à
dire que ce débat qu'on à propos de
l'europe est ce qu'on peut à la fois
élargir et approfondir
on l'a en matière 2007 et donc je
voulais dire juste et jusqu'à mon gars
tu en même temps qu'ils à la réunion du
g7 et la réunion des brics question si
je puis dire à l'est où il ya la chine
il ya ya la russie à l'inde et donc on a
l'impression que le monde du point de
vue de la gouvernance mondiale est en
train de s'organiser autour de deux
pôles ou de 2,2 deux régions qui sont
relativement séparées l'une de l'autre
ce qui va être dit tout à fait
intéressant mais vous l'avez bien dit
tous les deux à savoir effectivement 75
lorsqu'on a créé sur forum c'était un
forum économique et ce n'est pas une
institution internationale les résidus
sanctions prises n'ont pas d'obligation
juridique obligatoire et depuis quelques
années depuis son sommet les
déclarations des déclarations à
d'ailleurs le communiqué et préparez
bien avant et rappeler vue donald trump
un sommet du g7 au canada avait déchiré
le communiqué final parce que ça ne lui
plaisait pas en réalité ce g7 a voulu
s'ériger rené sorte de directoire
politique du monde et on voit bien
aujourd'hui que toutes les limites de
cela dès lors qu effectivement la russie
n'y est pas donc on peut prendre des
décisions voit que votre correspondant
en bavière disait qu'il y avait des
divergences donc quoi bien avant ces
divergences sur les volontés des a et
des autres et que ce directoire
politique n'est plus en situation
d'entraîner le monde entier car comme
vous l'avez dit avec la chine l'inde le
brésil qui vient de conclure un
partenariat avec la russie et bien c'est
de plus en plus difficile d'entraîner le
monde entier uniquement le g7 ce n'est
pas le moment de négociations avec la
russie a aussi dit tout à l'heure vous
les 10 meilleurs zelensky boris johnson
le premier ministre britannique
d'ailleurs hier s'est opposé à une
solution négociée maintenant on va
l'écouter on en reparle juste après
il n'y a pas d'accord que le président
zelaya qui puisse vraiment conclure
donc dans ces circonstances dj set c'est
les soutiens de l'ukraine dans le monde
entier qui doivent continuer à aider les
ukrainiens à reconstruire leur économie
à produire leurs céréales à les exporter
et bien sûr nous devons les aider à se
protéger et c'est ce que nous allons
continuer à faire qu'elle continue que
de
vous lire et à
écouter oui sur les dissensions au sein
de ce groupe qui en fait il faut bien
voir que il ya 7 6 participants qui
appartiennent aux l'otan puisse le japon
la plus-value quand même et
économiquement est extrêmement
importante donc son domaine c'est
l'économique c'est pas le militaire le
mythe rc7 c'est cette personne là
ensuite si vous voulez
concernant l'aide ou équipes qui peuvent
apporter elle est quand même sujette à
caution et on voit bien que les
dissensions essentiel porte en tout cas
entre la grande bretagne et la france
peut-être pour des raisons
conjoncturelles sur la capacité à
négocier plus ou moins vite on a vu les
très grandes ambassades entre boris
johnson et le président français on se
demande pourquoi parce que quelques
heures auparavant johnson avait dit
contrairement à la france il ne faut pas
négocier actuellement est un peu un jeu
un jusqu'au boutiste un peu un bout de
feu il est peut être vexé parce que
bayonne a dit que l'allemagne était le
meilleur allié des états unis il ya pas
longtemps or les britanniques essayé par
tous les moyens à être les meilleurs
alliés à la fois de trump auparavant et
de bail donne maintenant donc il se
taclent tous les côtés mais je pense que
sur ce point là il faut peut-être se
méfier un peu du jusqu'au boutisme de
boris johnson sachant qu'un jour ou
l'autre il faudra établir les meilleures
conditions possibles ou les moins pires
rumeurs conditions possibles pour
négocier
non mais quant au favori je souhaite
dire qu'il va falloir aider
économiquement l'ukraine je rappellerai
que les états unis sont aux avant postes
de cette aide de 40 milliards de dollars
de surcroît la commission européenne et
le conseil européens viennent de décider
d'une rallonge financière de 9 milliards
d'euros ce qui est quand même très
important donc on voit bien que les
déclarations de boris johnson c'est
peut-être pour essayer de se remettre
sur la scène internationale alors
s'exécuter fragilisé sur le plan de la
politique intérieure je voudrais revenir
sur la question de l'énergie veut dire
au fond le g7 en parle parce que les
rues mais ça il faut parler mais vire
les décisions ont été prises au niveau
de la commission européenne et de
l'union européenne et alors là donc sans
la grande bretagne depuis les proxy et
il ya eu des décisions relativement
importante sur essayer de réduire notre
dépendance par rapport au pétrole russe
on a beaucoup plus de difficultés sur la
question du gaz parce que là il ya des
dissensions bien connu entre d'un côté
l'allemagne qui reste encore dépendante
à 35 ou 40 % de viale rue le cpie et
pays comme la france qu'ils sont moins
mais je veux dire par là par rapport à
question de savoir si on a affaire à des
recommandations un peu vague un peu
vaseuse ou des débuts décision je crois
que c'est au niveau de l'europe au
niveau de l'union européenne qu'on
essaye de d'affirmer une gouvernance y
compris vis-à-vis dans nos rapports avec
là aussi le g7
moi je je répète quand je fais le bilan
du g7 et ce que les bois de l'eau dire
bien avant le rhin depuis qu'il existe
je trouve qu'il ya quand même un écart
entre les intentions qu'on avait est ce
qu'on a réussi à faire la gouvernance
mondiale est quasiment inexistante les
organismes internationaux dans cette
affaire-là moi je l'attends de la même
manière qu'eux avec le co vide
j'attendais une oms qui soit un peu plus
efficace et anticipatrice l' oms a été
suivi deux en matière de co vide la
l'onu l'onu par rapport à cette
affaire-là sert à quoi ou orner la
gouvernance mondiale donc je suis désolé
de dire ça moi qui suis plutôt optimiste
dans la vie pour lequel le verre est en
général à moitié plein là je trouve
qu'il est à moitié vide en tout cas le
g7 a tout de même voulu montrer son
unité face à
la russie dans cette dans cette guerre
on va écouter joe biden le président
américain il a donné le ton hier en
arrivant en allemagne
nous devons rester soudés nous parce que
quand ils espèrent depuis les débuts de
manière ou d'une autre de l'otan et
l'egypte est quotidien mais ça ne paye
c'est le cas
nous ne pouvons pas laisser cette
agression couvert de gesté lequel il
laissait sentir
détiennent hoggar kova beaucoup de
déclarations d'intention viens d'en
parler et en même temps quand même un
message d'unité de la part de ce g7
c'est important pour les ukrainiens
écoutez oui le message est là il est
important c'est le message solidaire
mais quand on est sur le terrain car les
réalités de la guerre est ici tous les
jours avec
chaque jour on apprend la mort de nos
amis des gens qu'on connaît ce n'est pas
du tout abstrait on connaît des gens qui
meurent sur le front c'est très souvent
malheureusement qu'ils ont 18 ans qu'ils
ont 25 ans qu'ils ont 30 ans 40 ans ce
sont nos amis ou les enfants même des
nos amis quand charger on voit les actes
terroristes et la russie les appels de
volodymyr zielinski de faire tout le
possible pour arrêter cette guerre avant
donc durant 7 cette année et voilà
jusqu'à décembre ça nous paraît très
long en fait et donc les discussions qui
suit qui que ça peut paraître irréaliste
puisque ceci ou cela puisqu'il ya des
téléromans ou autre argument parce que
ce n'est pas dans l'intérêt de tes
lettres autres partenaires ça nous
chagrine puisque tout simplement quand
vous vivez la réalité de la guerre vous
avez qu une soul volonté que ça cesse
immédiatement je vous rassure que si
justement la russie arrive à contrôler
le cren ce qu'il va faire justement sans
cette aide occidentale nécessaire il va
pas s'arrêter là et donc il va il y aura
une agression à suivre donc il serait
peut-être beaucoup plus intéressant de
concentrer fort il est question d'autant
en fait de de concentration d'efforts
d'al autant cours et les très importants
pour les partenaires occidentaux de
l'ukraine ont fait tout le possible qui
composent sur le terrain mais arrêtez
d'en peut terminer vraiment cette guerre
beaucoup plus rapidement et de manière
efficace le fait de les rallonger de
livres et je ne sais pas si césar gâtés
lors il nous en fout 1000 systèmes de ce
type ça ne joue que rallonger cette
guerre qui n'est n'est pas dans
l'intérêt ni de l'europe ni dairy crest
nuit en fait de tout le monde donc
rallonger la guerre ça veut dire créer
des problèmes supplémentaires pour
l'europe notamment l'eau et la famille
notamment les immigrés la russie va
jouer là dessus bien siens m'ont bien
sûr avec les vagues d'immigrés qui vont
arriver où ils vont arriver en europe
après la russie va transformer ce si un
arbre en fait h enfin un faiseur de
chantage donc il nous faut vraiment une
concentration des efforts n'est pas
faire des calculs de concentrer l'effort
pour arrêter pour procéder assauts de
montage de l'armée russe au plus vite
possible les soldats ukrainiens sont sur
le terrain et son incapacité de
combattre ils sont en nombre suffisant
en fait pour faire face à l'armée d la
russie il nous faut juste les armements
lourds justement et dans les délais qui
ne sont pas en octobre ou en novembre
il nous les faut maintenant et donc pas
inquiété de 10 systèmes ou vent système
il faut vraiment des systèmes à l'ombre
et je vous assure ça sera dans l'intérêt
de tout le monde c'est ne pas l'intérêt
de l'ukraine seuls ceux des l'intérêt de
toute l'union européenne de 17 et doute
tout à fait qu'il est question
occidental mais michel lagalaye les
livraisons d'armes elles ne vont pas
assez vite les sanctions ne sont pas
assez puissantes aujourd'hui la réponse
occidentale n'est pas la hauteur les
sanctions sont économique monsieur de
boissieu sera bien mieux placé que moi
pour répondre sur leur efficacité à
court moyen et plutôt long terme en ce
qui concerne les sanctionner d
emprisonnement en armement c'est
toujours très difficile de transformer
40 milliards en armement sur le front à
partir du moment où la russie a quand
même au bout après un certain nombre
d'erreurs a compris qu'il fallait
concentrer ses forces sur le saillant de
ces verres de lait ce qui est tombé dont
on savait tous qu'il allait tomber vous
voyez pas très bien comment il pourrait
faire autrement sa part c'est pas 16
canon caesar si vous voulez qu'ils
peuvent changer le cours des choses donc
quand vous avez dit tout à l'heure où
quand j'ai entendu dans un reportage que
le conflit pourrait être gelée en
novembre prochain moi j'aimerais bien
qu'ils se gèlent très vite au propre
comme au figuré parce que pour l'instant
la dynamique est du côté russe avec une
concentration des forces hall à
l'endroit où ça fait mal à l'endroit où
tentent d'obtenir leur objectif réduit
bien sûr de john bass mais qui dit que
l'armée ukrainienne va résister et qui
dit que sur son élan la russie n'ira pas
plus loin car si vous voulez réclamé le
dombass ça s'arrête pas un peu comme
tchernobyl qui s'arrêtait aux frontières
vous savez les radiers radiations les
poussières radioactives là pour vous ça
vraiment c'est par là la crimée en 2014
et pourquoi s'arrêterait-il autres et en
coin de janvier qui sont limite
administrative du donbass non pas du
tout par ailleurs je voudrais rajouter
quelque chose je trouve que cette mise
en scène du gsm a quelque chose
d'indécent au moment où comme vous
l'avez souligné cette boissieu
que le pétrole go que le laissant se
double de prix les économies
occidentales pour le supporter alors
qu'il ya des gens qui créent de la faim
et qui peut y avoir à nouveau des
émeutes de la faim donc moi je trouve
que c'est l'ancien monde c'est l'ancien
amant de que nous voyons maintenant et
si on veut passer comme l'a dit le
président l économie de guerre c'est
autre chose il faudrait se pencher sur
ce que c'est qu'une économie de guerre
la russie me semble-t-il est déjà bien
plus avancés que nous dans ce chemin là
parce que peut-être elle avait ce projet
depuis beaucoup plus on va reparler à la
russie patrick martin legner les
sanctions elles sont insuffisantes
aujourd'hui la réponse occidentale n'est
pas et c'est difficile à dire parce
qu'on essaye sursauter défi clé des
sanctions aujourd'hui sur l'or ils se
sont mis d'accord oui voilà des
sanctions sur l'or mais les lancers
seulement 5% des villes mortes à sion la
route
du kremlin dit que ça c'était pas un
problème pour eux de la même façon
qu'ils n'étaient pas un problème ce
défaut de paiement sur des intérêts de
100 millions de livres ou de dollars
parce qu'il s'était préparé à cela et
que c'était à cause du fait que
justement vers on va écouter je vous
coupe pour vous écouter on va voir
dimitri peskov le porte parole du
kremlin il a dit à ce propos je vais
vous laisser reprendre derrière
les paiements mentionné ont été reçus
par l'agent payeur le national s'est
elle-même depository le même jour ils
ont été rapidement remis au système
international des transactions sur les
titres pour un transfert ultérieur au
client les paiements dollars américains
ont eu lieu le 24 mai 2022 et les
paiements en euros le 25 mai 2000
vendent
voilà c'est la réponse de la russie à
cette idée de défaut de paiement sur sa
dette c'est ce qu'a annoncé bloomberg
notamment tout à l'heure oui et on est
en train de nous dire que l'occident se
puni lui-même un puisque la russie
semble honorer ses engagements
financiers
et il faut dire que la russie s'était
préparée depuis assez longtemps à ces
sanctions économiques et aujourd'hui
peut-être que à moyen terme je ne sais
pas cela aura une efficacité
mais toutes ces sanctions contre les
oligarques on n'en voit pas bien les
effets il pas y paraît qu'il y à de
l'inflation en russie mais pour
l'instant on n'envoie pas des effets
tangibles de la même façon que ce défaut
de paiement eh bien on n'en voit pas les
conséquences directement en d'autres
termes la russie quand même un sous
continent qui a noué des relations
internationales avec la chine les pays
du brics tout à l'heure là le brésil
vient de signer un partenariat important
avec la russie envoie bien qu'ils ont
contourné ces sanctions économiques et
quand return train de nous dire
finalement ça va affecter bien plus
l'occident et l'europe
lorsque ça a été dit lorsque demain il
faudra payer le prix du litre d'essence
de gasoil de 0 53 euro et qu'il faudra
payer encore plus nos factures de gaz et
d'électricité là effectivement je pense
que d'ores et déjà pour voir qu'il ya
une fracture et je pense que la russie
joue l'aide supérieur jusqu'au musée
madame bogard kova est tout à fait
justifié effectivement ce qui est de
l'intérêt c'est pas uniquement l'intérêt
de l'ukraine c'est l'intérêt de l'europe
on le voit bien aujourd'hui car avec ce
boycott cette crise alimentaire le fait
de ne pas pouvoir exporter des céréales
va provoquer effectivement des émeutes
de la faim on en parlait tout à l'heure
dans certains pays sub ceux de l'afrique
subsaharienne l'egypte le liban qui est
dans une situation catastrophique et
cela peut avoir des conséquences autant
migratoire sur l'europe et là
effectivement on verra que la sonata sur
terry s'effriter ça les opinions
publiques vont suivre derrière ces
sanctions écoutez les sanctions je pense
qu'il fallait les prendre donc je
commence par dire ça pour dire ensuite
que c'est pas complètement efficaces qui
ait pas d'ambiguïté dans mes propos
c'est pas totalement efficace pour les
raisons qu'on évoquait tout à l'heure
plus endurcis ils ont fait monter les
prix du pétrole et du gaz et plus ça
profite aussi d'une certaine façon à la
russie qu'on essaye d'atteindre donc la
russie compense par les valeurs par les
prix ce qu'elle peut sur les volumes et
quand vous regardez l'évolution des
exportations de la russie depuis
quelques mois sap a baissé bon leurs
importations et le rouble qui n'est pas
le seul extérieur russe de manière
paradoxale s'est beaucoup améliorée
depuis quelques mois avec des
exportations qui se maintiennent avec
cette compensation entre les prix et les
volumes d'autre part les importations
qui ont été réduites bon
les sanctions sont contournées c'est à
dire par lorient par l'est d'une
certaine façon et ça
l'attitude de la chine qui est quand
même je sais pas s'il faut dire qu'elle
est ambiguë ou pas ambigu parce que
depuis le début elle est pas tellement
du bon l'inde aussi je veux dire on
n'est pas tout seul il ya comme une
partie du monde qui est en train de
continuer à faire des affaires avec les
russes bon et ça il faut pas l'ignorer
troisième point l'opinion publique vous
parlez de l'opinion publique et la
population russe moi j'ai dirigé des
missions pendant qu'ils oublient aussi
européenne ah oui mais sans long de la
russie parce que les sanctions ça disait
aussi à faire en sorte que l'opinion
publique en russie des russes fassent un
peu pression sur leur gouvernement
alors la situation économique en aussi
aller compliquée vous avez parlé
l'inflation chômage la plupart de nos
entreprises et nos banques sont partis
beaucoup d'entreprises occidentales sont
partis il ya une montée du chômage et de
l'inflation montée du chômage si ça se
passait chez nous dans les pays
occidentaux y aurait une sorte de
pression de l'opinion publique on voit
bien avec 5% d'inflation en france un
peu plus 5% ce qui se passe c'est pas
par hasard qu'on est en train d'adopter
la loi sur le pouvoir d'achat les russes
et ça m'a frappé dans les nues quand
j'ai travaillé entre 92 et 98 sur là
aussi ils ont en eux ils ont par nature
par culture une sorte de cape de
résilience de capacité de résistance à
une dégradation de la situation
économique et sociale parce que pour eux
pour eux poutine est un génie parce que
ils essayent de restaurer la pyrrhus
quand je débarque à moscou en 92
gorbatchev qui était un génie pour nous
était un [__] pour les russes parce
qu'il avait en quelque sorte désagréger
l' empire us donc il faut bien voir que
l'opinion publique les russes en ce
moment il souffre dans leur vie
économique et sociale
ils ont besoin il ya des réunions
publiques qui est quand même il faut le
dire totalement verrouillé
ils sont en économie de guerre déjà et
ils sont déjà c'est verrouillé les
bandas du bien sûr mais je pense que
fondamentalement il ya beaucoup de
russes qui sont en train de soutenir ce
qui se passe et s'ils sont des vers
l'économie de guerre et du point de vue
du marché du blé on a parlé tout à
l'heure la chine devient maintenant le
premier importateur de blé russe or la
chine jusqu'à présent était importateurs
mais important par millions de tonnes de
blé américain or il se trouve que
maintenant le blé américain n'ayant plus
de débouché sur la chine va se retrouver
sur le marché à lui aussi alors c'est un
blé ogm etc mais les peuples qui ont
faim vont peut-être pas regarder s'il ya
beaucoup de gm dans le blé américain
donc ceux hélas si vous permettez
l'avenir excusez-moi de vous couper je
vous en prie l'afrique on en a parlé aux
nerfs
macky sall président du sénégal sénégal
préside l'union africaine jusqu'à la fin
janvier macky sall a été voir poutine à
sotchi qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'il a
dit macky sall de présence et des galets
il a dit voilà vous nous mettez dans une
position impossible sur le plan
alimentaire et aussi parce que vous nous
demandez à nous africains de payer de
payer nos vols les importations
africaines de blé russe de les pays en
roubles je t'assure et dont on n'a pas
parlé mais qui rajoute une contrainte
les russes nous demande de payer de
payer leurs exportations de importations
en robe et je répète un sujet sur lequel
l'afrique en ce moment est très
contrainte parce que les roubles ils
sont pas évidents à trouver et je répète
l'afrique vous l'avez dit d'afrique les
africains ils ont besoin comme tout le
monde ils ont besoin de manger et je
suis très inquiet pour les mois qui
viennent sur ce qui peut se passer dans
la certain nombre de pays africains où
ou du moyen-orient
les conséquences de cette guerre et puis
j'aimerais qu'on revienne aux sanctions
quand même ces sanctions occidentales
sanctions
renforcés au g7 en tout cas qui ont été
annoncées
même si elles ont un impact sur
l'économie russe patrick martin geniez
l'a vu il ya quand même des l'inflation
et du chômage il ya du chômage elles ont
quand même un impact
mais même si l'économie russe
s'effondrer vladimir poutine ça ne
l'arrêterait pas non je crois que il ya
l'aspect politique comme vous l'avez dit
il il est dans une une entreprise
d'impérialisme de reconquête des anciens
glacis soviétique
vous l'avez dit il a le soutien de la
population
mais quand même si de ma l'économie
russe devait s'écrouler je pense qu'il
pourrait y avoir un impact de la même
façon que certains jeunes russes ont
refusé de s'engager dans l'armée car
aujourd'hui vladimir poutine est tous
plus d'aller chercher des recrues dans
le parmi la population défavorisée et
qu' une contestation qui commencée bien
écoutez c'était
yahiaoui il ya quand même eu lors de la
de ce défilé du 8 mai victoire contre le
nazisme et il ya des gens qui ont refusé
de porter donc de porter le message de
la victoire qui ont désavoué la dmr
poutine ça reste une minorité il ya des
gens qui ont été arrêtés transportés
dans des commissariats parce qu'il y en
a quand même qui certaines personnes
courageuses qui acceptent de contester
le pouvoir en place et on sait que les
gens qui le contestent notamment des
journalistes dans un média en ligne
indépendant également également des
mères de famille kadia sur des gens qui
sont systématiquement gardés à vue dans
des commissariats avoir enfermé il y à
une terrible dictature d'une chape de
plomb mais si demain à l'économie russe
devait s'écrouler subitement imaginons
un super défaut de dette et bien même le
fait que la russie soit un son continent
à elle toute seule ne suffirait pas et
si demain également vladimir poutine
devait aller plus loin notamment
notamment en matière de menace nucléaire
on l'a bien vu que c'est facile de faire
des menaces nucléaires mais si demain il
devait mettre en cause la sécurité de la
russie je ne suis pas certain qu'il
serait suivi par l'état-major militaire
et politique pouvait retrouver à kiev
tetiana aux gars comme toi vous vouliez
réagir à tout ce qui est en train de se
dire
oui tout à fait on voit discutant fait
ici est de créer un trop fort je
m'excuse mais un peu naïf cette idée que
les sanctions économiques quelqu'un qui
lui nuisent à la vie des deux sociétés
russes qui lui va et puisse avoir un
impact sur justement les les
protestations ou qui d'autre manière de
changer le pouvoir et puis diminuer le
soutien de poutine
malheureusement ce convoi parce qu'on
est quand même voisin on a à plusieurs
réunions avec la russie on est plusieurs
liens de famille on parle leur langue on
voit ce qu'est ce qu'il pense en fait ce
qui est juste ce qu'il faut on voit
qu'ils sont malheureusement à cet état
de leur société absolument incapable de
changer les à court de l'histoire
puisque m s'il ya une possibilité de
changer le cours de l'histoire un récit
ça sera est ce qu'on espère en fait par
le coup d'état par l'état majeur
justement par les militaires par le kgb
par tout ce que vous voulez mais
malheureusement pas pas par la
population russe qui déjà pour la
plupart en fait selon les sondages
soutiens poutine même si ceux qui
soutiennent pas à poutine et sont
tellement peur de s'exprimer sans parler
de faits de faire quoi que ce soit de
tangible de réelles contre ce pouvoir
parce que on peut pas compter
malheureusement sur le peuple russe pour
le cours de l'histoire aujourd'hui
malheureusement je dis parce que ils
sont 140 millions et sont deux fois même
plus plus plus que les français en fait
imaginer 140 millions c'est énorme mais
malheureusement où les trouve dans
l'incapacité d'agir dans la capacité a
prises malheureusement par ce régime
autoritaire qui c'est qui s'est
installée progressivement durant vingt
ans on peut pas malheureusement pas
compter sur les routes on peut côté un
peu sur les baies le russe n'a c'est
plus il ya plus d'intrigués en tout cas
notamment si le cash and co le président
autoproclamé décidé sous cette pression
énormissime de poutine d'un trait d'un
aguer on a toujours des doutes mais si
toutefois ils donnent un ordre au
charbel russe d'un trait ici on a des
quand même un espoir qu'un homme deux
militaires eurosport ce maître d'un
autre côté ce que ne peut donc on ne
peut pas dire malheureusement pour la
russie je répèterai mon message
important c'est que ce bien dans
l'intérêt de tout le monde de faire
cette guerre courte puisque prolonger
serrières transformant le cren en
afghanistan à nos deuxièmes regagner ce
temps ça ne serait pas dans l'intérêt ni
de l'europe ni des états unis et de
l'ukraine nous nous sommes là tout près
on est on est beaucoup on a plusieurs
millions il ya bien sûr des gens qui
sont partis d'eux le crime il ya
toujours des mails est ok ceux-là qui
sont prêts à se battre nous avons besoin
de soutien et donc c'est dans l'intérêt
de tout le monde d'imposer le plus de
sacs sur possible bien sûr mais possible
aujourd'hui est de livrer autant dormait
mans pour vous pouvez pour arrêter c'est
à dire au plus vite possible
une longue guerre une longue guerre
froide c'est dans l'intérêt de personne
c'est dans l'intérêt surtout pas du
peuple ukrainien et des civils ukrainien
parce que l'atrocité de la guerre on la
voit de près nous nous en parlons enfin
nous avons l'air d'en parler de façon
froide ce qui n'est absolument pas notre
sentiment à tous ici autour de la table
et même emma bailleur mais il faut que
ça s'arrête mais les conditions ne sont
pour l'instant absolument pas réunies
vous avez devant vous une russie qui a
l'air déterminé qui ne recule sur rien
qui ne fait aucune aucune ouverture en
termes de négociations au moment où ça
aurait pu se faire
les ukrainiens ont voulu pousser leur
avantage très très long vous savez c'est
une affaire de balancer puis qui décide
c'est pas nous c'est une affaire entre
russes et ukrainiens donc pour l'instant
nous sommes dans une position
extrêmement délicate il faut que
financièrement l'ukraine soit soutenu ça
le rôle du g7 est important de se
prononcer sur ça que le g7 peut vraiment
jouer ensuite c'est l'otan c'est ce que
voulait actuellement moi je pense qu'une
des forces européennes serait quelque
chose de bien parce qu'il faut quand
même garder une certaine indépendance
mais ce qui va se décider à madrid dans
quelques jours c'est aussi un certain
nombre de d'éléments du style le mettre
sur pied une force de réaction rapide de
plusieurs dizaines de milliers d'hommes
et une force de réserve de 300 mille
hommes c'est quand même que le sale avec
des armements dont dispose l'europe et
l'occident bien sûr mais ce sont aussi
les objectifs qu est ce que ça va
devenir on parle quand même de désigner
la russie et la chine comme des
adversaires ça n'est plus le tout
azimuts du général de gaulle qui
permettait de développer une force de
dissuasion sans désigner l'adversaire on
dit également que les décisions de
l'otan qui seront des décisions très
engageante se feront à la majorité
qualifiée alors est-ce que ça engagera
ceux qui n'ont pas voté pour on ne sait
pas donc il y avait surtout une
internationalisation enfin la limite de
d'action les intérêts d'intervention de
l'otan serait mondiale alors bon on se
dit ou allons-nous et il me semble qu'il
ya beaucoup de parlements nationaux qui
vont se pencher sur cette question et je
dirais que le nôtre qui vient d'être élu
dans les conditions que nous connaissons
tous ça sera intéressant l'assassin de
ces défis de très très près on n'a plus
du tout le temps un dernier mot oui
derrière 10 secondes derrière la russie
et l'ukraine il y également le danger
chinois la chine face à taiwan et de ce
produit là on est vraiment scruter en
chine merci beaucoup merci beaucoup à
tous les trois sur ce plateau merci à
tetyana hoggar kova qui est en skaï pas
avec nous c'est la fin de ce débat
rester avec nous sur france24
l'information continue
[Musique]